auf der Suche nach der besten Art
Energie selbst zu erzeugen habe ich
schon alles probiert
alles fing an mit einem selbstgebauten
kurbelgenerator sieht sehr sehr fein aus
da muss jetzt das rein das ist richtig
ins same es ist schon hell über ein
eigenes Windrad
[Musik]
oh mein Gott das ist einfach komplett
grün Energie es sind zum Menschen großen
Hamsterrad mit dem ich sogar im
Fernsehen war
mit einem Abstecher zum
leitungswasserkraftwerk
beim stromgenerieren Beyblade
ein bisschen zum letzten Jenny Streich
den Fahrt Windrad
Wasserstoff
was ist Stoff ist das häufigste Element
im Universum auf der Erde wahrlich keine
Seltenheit und könnte nicht nur
theoretisch sondern auch praktisch alles
Betreiben von Autos die schon heute
Wasserstoff betrieben auf den Straßen
fahren über LKW bis hin zu
Containerschiffen und Flugzeugen Wasser
also H2O besteht aus zweimal Wasserstoff
und einmal Sauerstoff wenn eine
elektrische Spannung am Wasser angelegt
wird trennen sich die beiden Gase und
blubbern an die Oberfläche klingt simpel
also warum habe ich in meinen Videos
nicht schon lange versucht Energie aus
Wasserstoff zu gewinnen und damit wie
schon so oft mein Handy zu laden oder
Motoren zu betreiben vielleicht weiß
explosiv für uns damit zu gefährlich ist
nee also ja stimmt schon und ich muss
jetzt auch sagen dass ihr das nicht zu
Hause nachmachen sollte aber nee das was
nicht was mich davon abgehalten hat also
machen wir das mal und zuerst
produzieren wir dafür unseren eigenen
Wasserstoff dafür gibt's hier einfach so
ein Youtube Tutorial ich habe dafür so
ein Behälter und da kommen jetzt erstmal
natürlich unsere Ausgangsmaterial rein
Wasser
sehr gut zwei Löcher drin
genommen
dann zwei Flaschen
so ihr könnt es einfach rein drehen
bisschen Backpulver
und dann kommt das einmal drauf Biggi
noch den Minuspol
einen Pluspol
dann nehme ich den Strom in Form von der
neuen Volt Batterie lege ich jetzt dran
und dann blubbert jetzt hier schon wie
man sieht und das was da hochsteigt ist
im Wasserstoff und um den einzufangen
mache ich den Deckel drauf
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt Wasserstoff und es gibt
jetzt zwei Arten daraus Energie zu
gewinnen die erste
[Musik]
nee das Leben
die Batterie wird durch Netzteil
ausgetauscht
und dann
[Musik]
und mit dem Wasserstoff der jetzt dabei
entsteht gibt es zwei artenenergie zu
gewinnen die erste
Hilfe ja das wäre jetzt Explosion und
dabei wird tatsächlich extrem viele
Energie freigesetzt theoretisch kann man
diese Hitze jetzt für die
stallproduktion und vieles andere nutzen
und interessiert aber viel mehr die
zweite Art aus dem Wasserstoff Energie
zu gewinnen und zwar Strom und das geht
mit genau der Gerätschaft die ich hier
schon gebaut habe die kann nämlich
irgendwo gekauften Wasserstoff aber auch
schon mein selbst produzierten der sich
schon im Tank befindet mit Sauerstoff
einfach aus der Luft zu Wasser
zusammensetzen so dass die dabei frei
werdende Energie als Strom nutzbar und
auch messbar wird
mit eben kurzzeitig 1,5 Volt und wenn
ich mal kurz umstellen
60 mA das heißt ungefähr 0,1 Watt und
damit kommen wir der Frage warum ich
bisher nichts mit Wasserstoff gemacht
habe langsam auf die Spur weil am
liebsten würde ich mit diesem Teil jetzt
direkt das erste Wasserstoff E-Bike
betreiben stattdessen gibt es in unserer
gesamten Werkstatt kein einziges Gerät
egal wie klein für das der Strom aus
unserer DIY Brennstoffzelle erreicht an
bräuchte 50 mal mehr Leistung um damit
auch nur ein Handyladen zu können um
also herauszufinden ob oder wie aus
meinem Traum vom Wasserstoff E-Bike
vielleicht doch was wird mache ich mich
auf den Weg zu den BMW ix5 days in
Belgien wo ich weltweit führende
Ingenieure genau dazu befragen kann aber
als begeisterter Batterie
Elektroautofahrer der Wasserstoffautos
mehr als skeptisch gegenüber steht habe
ich davor erstmal die Gelegenheit zum
ersten Mal ein Wasserstoffauto zu fahren
das übrigens genauso ein Teil verbaut
hat nur das ist nicht so sondern so
aussieht und aus mir noch unbekannten
Gründen eine Million Mal besser ist
so los geht's mit der ersten Fahrt in
einem Wasserstoffauto das ist sehr
verrückt ich glaube kaum einer von euch
ist schon meine Wasserstoffauto gefahren
ich bin gespannt erste Frage wie viel
ps295 kW das heißt 125 kW aus der
Brennstoffzelle 170 kW außer kleinen
Leistungs- und das Wasser jetzt
rauskommen ist das schon das ist
Wasserdampf das ist ja total geil und
warum wir gar nicht fahren weil nämlich
die Heizung so hoch gedreht haben
ab geht's
auf jeden Fall extrem ruhig also man
schwimmt hier schon fast
also sehr ungewohnt für mich ist es dass
diese Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen die
hier im Auto stehen auch tatsächlich
stimmt kann ich von meinem Auto anders
und wenn man hier links aus dem Fenster
in den Spiegel schaut sieht man immer
wieder Wasserdampf rauskommt und da wir
hier gerade mit Energie fahren die durch
die Herstellung von Wasser freigesetzt
wird ist der Wasserdampf aus 100% Wasser
auch das einzige Abgas das entsteht
grundsätzlich wenn du so fährst also als
Daumen wer kommt alle 10 km machst du
Liter Wasser raus und wie viel du davon
siehst hängt natürlich einmal davon ab
wie viel Gas gibst ja und wie der Wind
geht und wie kalt draußen ist auch beim
Fahrzeug vor uns das neben natürlich
genauso ja aber das reicht nicht so gut
ist das tatsächlich beim Verbrenner auch
Wasserdampf ja das würdest das Wasser
kannst du nicht sehen trotzdem hat es
unübersehbare Auswirkungen auf die
Umwelt weshalb man auch beim
Wasserstoffauto genau hinschauen muss
denn wasserstoff ist nicht gleich
Wasserstoff wie wir vorhin gesehen haben
wird Wasserstoff üblicherweise durch die
Elektrolyse gewonnen unter Einsatz von
Strom und woher dieser Strom kommt ist
letztendlich genau wie beim E-Auto das
was darüber entscheidet wie CO2 neutral
die Verwendung der Brennstoffzelle
wirklich ist man spricht von grauem
Wasserstoff wenn der Hersteller Strom
durch fossile Brennstoffe wie Kohle oder
Erdgas erzeugt wurde es gibt blauen
Wasserstoff türkisen Wasserstoff und
noch einen ganzen Regenbogen aber der
heilige Grall ist der grüne aus z.B
Solarenergie oder Windkraft der Macht
aktuell erst einen Bruchteil der
Wasserstoffproduktion aus weshalb
effiziente Nutzung umso wichtiger ist
jetzt bin ich einen der Alternative zum
Verbrenner nicht ganz unerfahren wie ist
das denn wenn man bremst genau also das
Fahrzeug hat Rekuperation also hier ist
eine kleine leistungsbatterie verbaut
aber die hat genug Kapazität und deine
Bremsenergie aufzunehmen und außerdem
kann die Batterie dadurch kurzzeitig
enorme Leistungen an den Motor abgeben
mehr als die Brennstoffzelle alleine
könnte womit wir hier auf 400 und einem
PS sitzen
ja also es macht Spaß
das ist mein Gebäude das finde ich total
geil dieses alte und dieses moderne das
passt sehr gut zusammen direkt davor
fahren König mache ich natürlich immer
einmal dass ich direkt vor dem Park
[Musik]
ja so das ganze Teil war jetzt gerade in
dem Auto drin dass wir gefahren sind das
hier sind wahrscheinlich die Tanks wir
fangen jetzt einfach mal an von Anfang
an da kommt quasi zum Tanken Wasserstoff
rein geht dann hierdurch in die Tanks
geht da einmal nach hinten und was
passiert hier also durch diese kleine
dünne Leitung geht der Wasserstoff in
das Brennstoffzellensystem hinein ja in
dem Brennstoffzellensystem reagiert der
Wasserstoff in der Zelle zusammen mit
dem Luftsauerstoff wodurch wie auch bei
meiner Brennstoffzelle Strom fließt nur
ebenso viel um damit ein ganzes Auto
bewegen zu können und jetzt erfahre ich
auch warum anders als bei meiner
diy-brennstoffzelle wird z.B nicht
stinknormale Stahlwolle als Elektroden
verwendet sondern flache und mit Platin
beschichtete schwammartige Materialien
die eine noch viel größere Oberfläche
bieten damit Strom von einer Elektrode
zur anderen fließt haben wir Wasser
verwendet weshalb unsere Brennstoffzelle
für ihre geringe Leistung nicht nur groß
sondern auch extrem schwer ist die
Industrie packt dafür statt Wasser eine
sogenannte Pulli mehr Elektrolyt Membran
dazwischen die das was das Wasser bei
uns macht noch viel besser kann und
extrem dünn ist ja vielleicht gesehen
wie bei uns der Stromfluss stark
zurückgeht sobald die Bläschen
aufgebraucht sind ist die direkt am
Stahlschwamm kleben weil dann weniger
Sauerstoffkontakt zu Elektrode hat
Hightech Brennstoffzellen haben deshalb
eine Geste Fusion Layer die die beiden
Gase gleichmäßig verteilt an die
Elektroden bringt das ganze ist dann
eine Art Hightech Sandwich von denen
dutzende benötigt werden und jedes davon
besteht aus Materialien die man als
Normalsterblicher einzeln leider gar
nicht in die Finger bekommt aus meinem
Wasserstoff E-Bike wird also erstmal
nichts aber eine Sache die wir bisher
gelernt haben wird's mir trotzdem
ermöglichen tatsächlich Geräte mit
meiner wilden Brennstoffzelle zu
betreiben sobald ich von meiner Reise
nach Hause kommen aber dazu später mehr
das ist sehr cool also total geil weil
das Innenleben zu sehen ach und hier aus
dem kam quasi dann der der Wasserdampf
den wir vorhin gesehen haben die
Abluftanlage das ist die das was du da
siehst das geschnitten ja das ist die
Abluftanlage das ist halt was von der
Luft übrig bleibt das heißt also primär
der Stickstoff unter Wasser geht dieser
doch sehr große Tank hält sechs
Kilogramm Wasserstoff klingt jetzt
erstmal wenig aber bei normalem
atmosphärischen Druck außerhalb des
Tanks würde das so viel Volumen wie ein
LKW brauchen und da man sich schlecht
und Berlin in LKW Größe ans Auto binden
kann steht der Tank unter 700 bar Druck
derselbe Druck wie 7000 Meter unter
Wasser weshalb das ja nicht irgendein
Tank sein kann also von so einem Tank
wenn ich mir zum Querschnitt davon
vorstelle wie viel ist davon jetzt diese
Wand die dafür sorgt dass der
Wasserstoff nicht raus explodiert der
Tank selbst der besteht eigentlich aus
drei Schichten innen drin ist ein
kunststoffleiner das ungefähr so dick
das ist das eine Wasserstoff eigentlich
drin hält und damit das Ding mechanisch
stabil ist ja und diesen hohen Druck
aushält wird der mit Kohlefasern
umwickelt und ganz oben drauf aber kommt
noch was Schutz genau das ist unter
anderem ist es auch ein Brandschutz
könnte mit dem Fahrzeug in Unfall
verwickelt sein wo Benzin anfangen ja
dann darf das Benzin was brennt ja nicht
unseren tankanze ja wie fällt sich das
hier ist das realistisch dass das
Brennen oder explodiert also unsere
Fahrzeuge sind grundsätzlich nach allen
Crash Standards abgesichert ja das heißt
sie haben alle craschtes gesehen und
natürlich darf bei so einem Verständnis
niemals auch nur irgendwas undicht
werden diese Fahrzeuge sie sind auch
noch mal gegen eine Wand gedonnert und
dann ist nichts passiert richtig also
wirklich eine frontrash auch Seiten
Seiten Crash ist ja auch immer kritisch
also da da Drink nichts ein und tritt
auch nichts aus beim Fahren fällt mir
auf dass mir nichts auffällt ich kann
wie von meinem Auto gewohnt mit nur
einem Pedal fahren gehe ich vom Gas
bremst das Auto durch Rekuperation bis
zum Stillstand ohne dass ich ein anderes
Pedal dafür brauche der für mich einzige
große Unterschied der gleichzeitig der
größte Vorteil und Nachteil von
Wasserstoff als Energiequelle ist ist
das Tanken Tankstelle aber wir wollen
natürlich nicht an den normalen
Zapfsäulen sondern wir wollen natürlich
zu der wasserstoffzapfsäule wenn der
Kreditkarte reingemacht und dann wenn
man sich einmal auf so nehme
Laserpistole hier drauf und drück den
Hebel Pan dann ist er fest und
puh da geht jetzt rein
so das war es genau 9 Euro pro 100
Gramm eine Vollladung von leer bis voll
dauert drei bis fünf Minuten mein E-Auto
braucht dafür selbst an der
schnellladesäule zehnmal so lang hier
kostet ein Kilogramm Wasserstoff 10 €
wodurch ein voller Tank mit dem das Auto
laut BMW 500 km weit kommt 60 € kostet
obwohl mich der Tankvorgang echt
überzeugt hat ist dieser auch der größte
Nachteil denn Strom und Sprit gibt's
überall die Wasserstofftankstelle
mussten wir aber gezielt suchen denn es
gibt in ganz Europa nur knapp 200
immerhin fast die Hälfte davon in
Deutschland ein klassisches Problem es
macht für viele noch wenig Sinn sich in
Wasserstoffauto zu kaufen weil es
weniger Tankstellen gibt und Firmen
bauen keine Tankstellen weißt du wenig
Wasserstoffautos gibt unterm Strich
steigen die Investition aber in
Wasserstoff als Energieträger sowohl bei
Staaten als auch bei Firmen Deutschland
kooperiert mit Namibia um in der Wüste
Wasserstoff zu produzieren der dann zu
uns transportiert wird Microsoft hat
letztes Jahr z.B einen
wasserstoffzellensystem gebaut das als
Notstromgenerator für ihre Server dient
und die aktuellen Dieselgeneratoren
ablösen könnte und das BMW in
Wasserstoff investiert habt ihr an der
kleinen Serie des tx-5 hydregen ja
gesehen die übrigens nicht für die
Serienproduktion geplant und nicht
käuflich erwerbbar ist dabei wurden und
werden die Brennstoffzellen übrigens
hauseigen von BMWs Ingenieuren selbst
entwickelt unter anderem von den mit
denen ich heute spreche wasserstoff kann
für alles benutzt werden aber das heißt
nicht das Wasserstoff auch für alles
benutzt werden sollte wie Jürgen Guldner
selbst sagt salopp gesagt BMWs
wasserstoffchef er sieht Wasserstoff
eher bei großen Fahrzeugen bis hin zu
LKWs Schiffen und Flugzeugen weil die
Nachteile davon eine Batterie zu
verwenden mit ihrer Größe zunehmen
während ein kleines Auto für die Stadt
wohl auch in Zukunft direkt mit Strom
fahren wird aber wenn man so Herstellung
von Wasserstoff ist Strom braucht warum
tankt man da nicht direkt den Strom wie
beim Auto naja man spart sich dadurch
eine große und schwere Batterie das
Tanken geht schneller und man kann mit
Wasserstoff den Strom auch speichern da
Wind und Sonne natürlich nur dann Strom
produzieren wenn Wind und Sonne da sind
und nicht zwangsläufig immer dann wenn
wir Strom brauchen außerdem müssen Strom
und Wasserstoff erstmal von A nach B
kommen wobei beides seine vor und
nachteile hat bin jetzt wieder daheim
und die Idee die ich mir von BMW X5
abgeschaut hat ist es umgesetzt der
Strom kommt hier rein der relativ gering
ist und wird von diesem
zwischenspeichern hier zwischen den Kopf
und erleuchtet das man ist total geil
kann kurzzeitig immer mehr Leistung
bringen wie die Tiere eigentlich kann
und dadurch reicht es für die LED vielen
Dank an den BMW Group für diese
Erfahrung und auch für Unterstützung bei
diesem Video bei denen ihr hoffentlich
genauso viel gelernt habt wie ich